[Music]
let's get to work
charlie very quickly Sons of Anarchy is
getting a new update can we see your
character in a flashback at all with the
new chapter of it all no there would be
so honestly it was funny I had the
deepest experience of my career coming
out of that yeah he's a solid guy
I had becomes that character becomes so
deeply integrated into who I was and I
hadn't I literally didn't realize until
the day we wrapped and we put him to
rest and I I felt I went through a
period of like two or three weeks of
like real bereavement and I have his cut
and you know people have been to my
house and asked if they could try it on
and I said no one will ever put that cut
on again like that we got to respect
that dude and he's you know he's not
with us anymore and so I would never
bring him back from the dead for
something like that I just you know it
for me in my own sort of silly way but
it was you know seven years in my life
he sort of became sacred to me so that's
a while you won't see Charlie on the
small screen reprising his role as Jax
teller you can catch him on the big
screen in his new film Papillon
something tells me you can be quite
savage there's so much for you mentally
and physically also with these roles I'm
sure because you guys have to lose
weight right yeah we did yeah I mean
Charlie lost far more violin by the end
of it I was pretty worried about do you
have a number I was down to 145 again
for this but I think I probably started
at about 180 or some least maybe like 35
pounds you're a little worried about I'm
very all this yeah how could you not be
I mean it's a it's a very intense
experience as it is filmmaking and this
one especially it's not that big the
glitz and glamour of Hollywood we
weren't out there going back to our
trailers every two seconds is the
sending it in the mud and hanging out
and watching Charlie starve so yeah I
was I was a bit concerned oh he's all
right
[Music]